what you're doing is madness  there's nothing you can do to stop me  elbows  [Music]  grinder wills a man who wants to make  the world a better place  the means by which he wants to achieve  that it's not necessarily what everybody  else is agreeing on  it was you who said we could reshape the  world  but it was our birthright  historically wizards and witches have  not been treated well by people  we have to remember that people can also  be very brutal  and that is hatred grow stronger and  stronger  do you really intend to turn your back  on your own kind  dumbledore and grindelwald had created  some very strong bonds and they were  sharing a common dream and then it  shattered  no the two biggest wizards seem to  represent the two sides of this wall  our wall  begins  today  with or without you i'll burn down their  world  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  you